in the last few hours dramatic footage
has emerged online depicting a man
believed to be former soldier Sean Emery
attacking and abducting a woman that's
him
a woman's missing and Sean Emery is our
suspects is anyone gonna tell me what
problem is you're under suspicion for
assault and kidnapping you do know that
your suspects a national hero two tours
in Afghanistan one in Iraq and how do we
repay his service
you won't tell me where she is what
happened between you and her she kissed
me
she got on a bus that's her lasso since
say what happened this ain't what
happened none of this happened what do
you mean he's gone
Deut escaped from an emergency exit run
facial rec make him a target
Shawn claims this is some happy
fabricated most anything is possible
these days if properly done it's
impossible to prove
what have you tiptoeing around sir I
think someone's tampering with evidence
we don't know whose turf we're trading
on
I understand you have this drive but
counterintelligence can rarely see the
whole picture
I learned when they say move along
nothing to see there lie
please be calm I am between rules no
scared I thought you knew what was at
stake you would walk away and pretend
this never happened
the intelligence community has hurt a
lot of people we need to find a soldier
find out which school is daughter ghost
if you could see we were working on I'm
talking about images as I'll haunt you
for the rest of your life while you're
watching everybody else don't ever
assume there isn't somebody watching me
[Music]
you
you